est il possible de manger pas cher et
qui libre et pour les étudiants de la
ville de tours difficile de concilier
les deux j'ai pris un menu mac do un mac
firth avec des potatoes un sandwich et
un fanta ça doit coûter combien tous à
4,95
c'est pas très fin mais ces pratiques
quoi quand le midi on a la flemme de
contrer
c'est juste à côté on lui c'est pas cher
burger pizza beagle tacos avec 25
chaînes de fast food pour cent quarante
mille tourangeau tout se place sur le
podium national du nombre d'enseignants
par habitant un contraste saisissant
alors que la ville est labellisé cité de
la gastronomie
si la restauration traditionnelle n'est
pas en concurrence directe
certains réflexes venue de ces enseignes
se font ressentir parfois effectivement
on se rend compte qu il ya il ya des
baisses de fréquentation ou alors tout
du moins des doléances de la part de
clients qui viennent dans un restaurant
comme le mien et qui veulent manger en
une demi-heure le midi c'est toujours
très compliqué mais fast-food veut-il
forcément dire malbouffe pour cette
enseigne
la réponse est non elle propose de
manger sur le pouce en le présentant à
ses clients que des produits frais vous
commandez notre bar guerre chez nous il
est fait devant vous le milkshake
pareilles idées sans pension artisanal
fait devant vous et encore une fois
j'insiste là dessus la qualité de la
nourriture elle est 100% frêche
parions que le pomme de terre c'est tous
les jours les leggings fait quasiment
tous les jours en effet tous les matins
enfin d'après les chiffres de la cci
touraine en cinq ans 227 fast food ont
été créés sur le territoire de la
métropole